I think it's time to move past
simple cosmetic changes to the site.
So far, you've used media
queries to change simple things,
like background color and what not,
but you can also you use media queries
to change the entire layout of the page.
In fact, this is how developers
accomplish responsive design.
By using media queries like minwidth and
maxwidth, developers can change
the entire layout of the page.
>> Right, the point at which the page
changes layout, is called a break point.
And depending on how
your site is laid out,
you might have one or
several break points.
>> You know what, let's take a look at a
few examples of pages using breakpoints.
Afterwards, I'll show you
a few more pages, and
you tell me,
how many breakpoints they've used.